so we've been dealing with polynomials
for a little bit of time a little bit of
time formerly at the moment but actually
a long time ever since we're really why
you're right the first time you touched
like linear equations and then had to
graph them right those were pullin em
was just the very well more or less the
simplest kind we ever had to deal with
right we just didn't give them this
fancy name because we didn't want to
freak you your thirteen-year-old brains
out but you've been dealing polymers for
a long time and now finally we're kind
of really digging deep into how do these
things work
which is why adding comma no mules
subtracting polynomials multiplying
polynomials all of these things are
really easy they just kind of follow all
the algebraic rules that you already
know division though which is just like
the next operation turns out to be a bit
of a headache though a totally
manageable headache just when you first
look at something like for instance
could you write down with me and I want
sure we come up with and how about
something like this you can drop that
down when you look at something like
this for the first time you're like
where do I even begin that guy at the
top I've crafted to be awkward and
difficult to factorize in fact you
comment factorize it not not nicely and
then that guy down the bottom doesn't
seem to want to go into the top is no
nicely canceling like when you first
introduced to got introduced to limits
remember when you had to do stuff like
this limit as H approaches 0 of and then
you had some fraction some quality about
the top in H like a quadratic and
something like this down the bottom and
you knew you knew fingers crossed if you
did everything right then you would get
an H minus 3 on the top and you'd cancel
cancel on everything was nice and neat
and you could move on to the next
question in the exam right but this is
not like that this is a mess where do
you even go right so we're going to
spend some time working out what to do
with this and it's an algorithm it's a
process that you can go through so most
of your time and effort is really going
to be on answering that question of how
do you do this what's the algorithm what
are the steps what's the recipe I need
to go through ok you will come at the
end of this lesson feeling good because
you can do this right but much more
important than how you always have to
ask this question in that's right is why
do we even care about this at all
like what's what's the point of all this
and I'm going to
give you hopefully by the end of this
we'll see how we go for time mrs. Lee's
a bit rusty of them say I'm gonna give
you three reasons for why and
conveniently I promise I didn't do this
entirely on purpose but all three
reasons start with the letter I I'm
partly obsessed with alliteration so I
guess that's why now I will tell you
what the three reasons are but none of
them will really make any sense until I
show you how to do this okay but I will
tell you what they are just to whet your
appetite
the first reason is in sight math is
about understanding right you want to
understand an object turns out if that
object is a polynomial then dividing it
can give you great insight into what
actually makes it tick that's the first
reason the second reason is we know how
to do very simple integration and
finding of primitives but only for a
very small family of functions really
nice neat ones okay now that's going to
grow and expand all the way through next
year but polynomial division it turns
out is one of the really handy tools
which allows you to integrate like a
wider variety of functions things like
this which you would think I don't have
a rule for that yet
well Palermo Division will help is there
okay and the last ones a bit like a
philosophical reason it's the hardest
one to explain but it's kind of a
neatest one and we'll leave it to the
end which is that it illustrates
polynomial division as a process
illustrates something really neat about
algebra as a whole because that's what
this is all that okay so that makes
sense that's where we're going I'm gonna
now talk to you about how and hopefully
as we go through then Y will become
clearer and I'll explain them all at the
end okay now I started out with this guy
we will tackle this one but before you
get to polynomial division you need to
think back to just regular division so
maybe just leave this one to one side
and maybe on the right hand side make a
little subheading for me which is
numerical division
okay someone to give me a one digit
number seven thank you and someone give
me a three-digit number
315
I wonder that's going to divide through
probably not we'll find out in a second
okay now we learn way back in Year seven
how to deal with divisions like this
right we call it long division when we
wrote it like this because I mean unless
it was a small number like 34 which you
could look at and say yep I know what
that is you have to kind of go through a
process to work out what will be what's
the answer by the way it starts with a Q
there's a funny name the question what
will the quotient be and more likely
than not because we came up with these
numbers randomly there will be a left
over bit which we call the remainder
right so we can't see this automatically
at least unless unless you can in which
case that's good for you most of us
cannot so we're going to start an
algorithm and as we go through this I
want you to think about what the steps
are because they're going to directly
import over here what's the very first
thing that I do
it was four years ago who is a long time
right
what are we gonna check hi okay so I'm
gonna this guy by the way we said that's
going to be a question and the remainder
this is the divisor that think doing the
dividing this is the dividend okay so
I'm gonna check if the divisor seven
goes into three and unsurprisingly it
does not so then what do I do yeah I
take the next part of the dividend as a
whole it's 31 okay that I can do some
sevens do you fit into there how many
sevens four by the way I skipped a digit
I really should have said it never fits
into three right but then it does fit
into four okay what do I do with this
for being bad okay so before I get to
the subtraction where does 28 come from
you're going to take this four and
you're going to multiply out the front
gives you 7 times 4 is 28 right and now
I'm gonna do my subtraction which gives
me in this case 3 ok hit pause right
this is kind of like the choreography of
a dance you just did four steps and we
kind of all kept it in our head at least
we kind of did if you remembered right
what were the four steps think right the
first thing was we divided 7 into rather
than the whole thing we divided into a
small thing because our brains can
handle that right that was the first
step we divided right that gave us four
what was the next thing we did from
there where did we go yet we multiply
namely we multiply this part of the
question by the device we started with
okay then what
then we did a subtraction okay and then
what do we do that one last step we
actually haven't done it which is it
sneaky haven't written it down can I can
I do this anymore can I divide any more
into three no that was kind of the point
right if I divided if I had 21 here and
I had extras left over I haven't done
the division correctly okay I can't do
this anymore
so I've kind of got to go back to the
first step that I did which is to take
more digits until I can write so I'm
gonna get back this where do I get my
extra digits from yeah this guy down
here like so Wow we got a multiple of
well done okay that's nice
in other words we carried down this next
digit right Karrie and then we start all
over again the dance recommences I can't
we're going to go through a game we're
going to divide conveniently this time
we get exactly five right to
double-check cause that all doesn't
always neatly happen right we then go
back through right you just did step one
again now we're going to multiply which
gives us 35 now what we subtract at this
point I no longer have any more digits
to carry what does that zero mean down
there what's his final number that's the
remainder okay now you remember how to
do this
hopefully jiggled some part of your
memory there I can now summarize this
joy result by saying okay this guy over
here you might as well actually because
we're going to use all of this language
in terms of the polynomials right I want
to remind you this is called the divisor
what was this guy again the big number
the dividend this are that answer is
that one which starts with Q the
question and I already have an R there
to remind us that that's called the
remainder okay but I can write a
statement now down the bottom here which
takes all four of these numbers one two
three four and combines them into one
nicely equation namely that if we
started with I'm gonna stay with that
color actually if we started with our
original 315 it equals to the divisor
multiplied by the quotient plus the
remainder it's kind of nice and neat you
can just read it from left to right okay
seven times that's a bad multiplication
sign 45 and it just so happens that I
remainder is zero okay if my remainder
was two or three it would be hanging out
on the end here okay so do we remember
this are you feeling comfortable is your
brain happy hopefully it's familiar
enough even if you have done this for a
long time you like yeah this is ringing
bells I'm good okay